president Trump threatening to seal the
southern border after talks to reopen
the government stall we're also learning
the president Trump is skipping his
annual New Year's Eve party in Mara Lago
due to the shutdown Fox News confirming
now that Nancy Pelosi soon to become
Speaker of the House is not in DC she's
on vacation White House Sarah Wright
House press secretary Sarah Sanders
going after the Democratic leader
earlier right now what we've seen from
her is that she's unwilling to actually
do anything until she gets her
speakership she's more willing to
protect that and Republicans calling
Senator Chuck Schumer a hypocrite for
comments he made about border security
in 2009 illegal immigration is wrong
plain and simple until the American
people are convinced that we will stop
future flows of illegal immigration we
will make no progress on dealing with
the millions of illegal immigrants who
are here now and on rationalizing our
system of legal immigration we must do
as much as we can to gain control of our
borders as soon as possible
so Lawrence I've been thinking for a
couple days we have to talk about this a
little bit yesterday is there a possible
deal to be made here that the president
gets let's say 2 million for the wall 2
million or 2 billion in exchange for
something like daca right because it's
clear that once the Democrats take over
on January 3rd they can pass a clean
funding bill with no money for the wall
which possibly could pass the Senate is
that a deal that could possibly work do
you think no I don't think a deal is
possible because they don't agree with
the symbolic measure right they don't
believe that the whole theory of the
wall the campaign trail him going down
the escalators all of that image to
their voters they just can't vote for
anything like that and so they will
never give him the wall because of the
symbolic measure but I think this
highlights something looking at Chuck
Schumer what changed
what chase with Barack Obama get right
something has to change and that's why I
started the last segment by saying I
feel like the entire debate is
disingenuous because they know and I
know they know because they said it in
the past you just cannot have an open
border right candy uh it's interesting
because I like that that Chuck Schumer
is being confronted with his own words
here and you know as we as we make
resolutions for the coming here you have
to look back on the resolutions you made
last year
did you fail yourself you know go back
and look at last year's list and the
year before and I think that's what some
of Democrats have to do because they
talk a big game but for a lot of their
voters this is a NIMBY issue not my
backyard and and they want to see
something done on immigration and you
know he acts so high and mighty now and
so self-righteous and he thinks he's so
much better than the president in terms
of how he argues about immigration and I
may actually agree with truck somewhere
on certain points but when he said just
a few years ago people who went to the
United States without our permission are
illegal aliens and illegal aliens should
not be treated the same as people who
entered the United States legally that
is in diametric opposition to well
statement said he probably still
believes a version of that and Jenna
died out one thing I think Democrats
push back on I know you think it's just
the symbolism of the wall but to a lot
of Democrats we feel like the president
is just saying the wall will fix it it's
the wall end-all-be-all
by the way Mexico is gonna pay for it
now taxpayers have to it doesn't seem
like the president's talking about a
comprehensive fix and just focusing on
yeah exactly yeah like a broader plan I
think one of the that's true that's a
fair point I think I think it would do
him justice to actually broaden out from
the wall and talk about the other issues
as well but you talked about you know
what changed one of the things that
changed was Trump Trump made this issue
a prominent issue Republicans oftentimes
don't put this as the lead issue this
was a guy who was out on a campaign
campaign trail talking about immigration
first talking about this wall talking
about how Mexico was gonna pay for it
which I thought was a mistake at the
time because I didn't see that happening
but he put it front and center and by
virtue of him doing that everybody that
loathed him now had to hate that policy
I mean Chuck Schumer sounds like Donald
Trump in that in that clip that we heard
he's echoing the very same talking
points but now because this is Trump's
issue him because the wall has become a
priority for Trump when they oppose
Trump they have to oppose that measure
even if it's counterintuitive to what
they've been saying for a very long time
so I wonder how much of this is
opposition to Trump or opposition to the
actual policy well as I think a lot of
it the president has talked about
immigration in terms of filling some of
the labor shortages here and he's talked
about needing workers and you know
you're never going to hear most the
press talk about or cover the kind
statements that he's made but you know
also can seem hypocritical but the
president also talks about the walls oh
it's a force field
it's not necessarily a rice field and
it's not going to stop every type of
illegal immigration and it's not going
to stop drugs from coming in because
drugs come in through San Ysidro through
the the main ports of entry that's and
and there is a that is actually not the
best way to combat the drug problem in
this country who is another way other
yeah yeah this is why the event the
argument isn't go anywhere because
there's this there's this weird fallacy
that if somebody says well the wall
won't prevent X that negates the premise
of the wall actually yeah the wall won't
prevent overstayed visa visas but a
fence won't prevent a falling rock but
complot conflating the two you actually
negate the benefits of either right so
you can actually say if you want
something here's what you do for the
fence you could put up a fence and
here's what you do for the overstayed
visa the problem here okay so that's
that argument it's gone right you can
use the fence for this you can use this
for that you don't need to do that
anymore
we should move on but we can't when it's
personal right so this is now personal
because there is no impersonal reason to
reject a compromise and Donald Trump is
willing to make a deal because he likes
making deals and let's face it he's been
moving toward the middle any time you're
going to embrace daca
seriously Marie if he's gonna piss off a
lot of people if he embraces daca but he
is going to make it he will is willing
to do anything for that wall and it's
idiotic but if a Democrat
that nobody will budge because he knows
that you can get piece by piece he is
willing to give yes and for what
but the point is it's not about him now
it's about it's about Chauncey you know
Chuck and Nancy right now they're in
there right now they're in it this is
like a divorce that stays together
because of the kids what you need right
now is a mediator right you need a
mediator to come in there
the mediator has to be an engineer who
tells you exactly what is needed for the
specific parts of the country because
God knows these politicians don't know
what it is so they sit there and they
fall back into their same arguments well
the walls not gonna fix X because well
we'll deal with that here's what the
wall is good for we do know that they
have walls around their compound so they
have walls around their swimming pools
they have walls around their at wherever
she's staying in Hawaii has a wall so
yes you're right about Dhaka and
conservatives if Dhaka means amnesty
right if dhaka it equals amnesty there's
a very loud party attempts were pushing
this agenda that trump is actually
offering it would be hailed as a
humanitarian effort by the media because
it would lend it would help the job
market with lower middle and it would it
would just create more jobs and it would
create a pathway to citizenship the
media would love this but unfortunately
Trump's doing it any time Trump does
something the media has to hate it we
will see if he does veto some sort of
bill that he gets once Congress comes
back in in a few days keep watching it